Speaker 1: So let's now review some of
these clips of Trump lawyer Aleena Haber
asked about the documents and the empty folders
marked Top Secret and all of it. So as a reminder,
one of the things we learned last week was
that among the documents recovered by the
FBI from Trump's house, there were also empty
folders marked top secret. Now, obviously,
if you see an empty folder marked top secret,
you say, well, where's the document that was in
it? It's extraordinarily unlikely that Donald
Trump took empty folders. So there's probably
more documents somewhere. Trump attorney Alina
Haber was asked about this and she started joking
about memes and invisible documents. Check this
out, obviously. And then the other thing, too,
that we can't get past is that these
envelopes, most of them were empty.
Speaker 4: What is that? We saw this. I don't
know. I saw this meme that was very funny
on Instagram, I believe it was. And notice.
Speaker 1: That she says, I don't know what it
means and quickly switches to talking about memes.
Speaker 4: That it's amazing. At first it was
the codes to the nuclear weapons. Now it's
invisible. Classified document. You know,
it could mean anything. I don't know. It could
mean that they gave those documents to Nora and to
the FBI prior, as we know, which they had done.
Speaker 1: Now, think about that. This is the
best. Now she gives explanations that make no
sense. Her first claim is maybe the thought.
The top secret folders were empty because Trump
returned the documents. You're saying he would
return the documents and not the folder? That
doesn't make any sense whatsoever. So that
one's not believable.
Speaker 4: It could
mean there was nothing in them.
Speaker 1: There was nothing in them,
so there was nothing in them. Also doesn't
make sense because Trump's legal team and
Trump himself have insisted that the documents
there were documents that they shouldn't be able
to be reviewed as evidence by the Department of
Justice. So if there were no documents, why would
Trump be arguing that the documents shouldn't
be be reviewed by the FBI? If there were no
documents, he would say there were no documents.
Speaker 4: It could mean they're invisible. If
you're not in administration, I truly don't know.
Speaker 1: Okay, then there might be invisible
documents. So as as always, the explanations
contradict. Maybe there were never any documents
in there. Then why did Trump's legal team build
a defense based on the fact that there were
documents there? That doesn't make any sense.
Maybe he returned the documents, but he kept
the folders. That doesn't make any sense either.
It only creates more questions. And by the way,
just a really funny extra note from this
interview. She did try to pivot to Hunter Biden.
It's beyond parody at this point, but she tried.
Speaker 4: Meanwhile, we have Hunter
Biden. Who has the laptop? Well,
nothing's happening there. I don't
even see.
Speaker 1:
The laptop from hell. And it just won't be
investigated by anybody. So the Trump legal team
at odds with itself about what is going on. And
what we are very rapidly learning is this is very,
very bad. Make sure you're following
us on Instagram at David Pakman show.